[موسيقى]
تقنيه جديده في البناء تجعل بناء البيت
اسرع من شراء سياره جديده من الوكاله في
الظروف الحاليه
[موسيقى]
خلال 330 ساعه اي اقل من اسبوعين تستطيع
هذه الطبيعه الثلاثيه الابعاد بناء بيت من
طابقين بكل تمديداته الكهربائيه والصحيه
ولا تحتاج لاكثر من اربعه عمال لانجاز
المهمه الطباعه الثلاثيه الابعاد دخلت
قطاع البناء قبل سنوات لكن هذه الطبيعه
التي تزن اكثر من اثني عشر طنا قد تكون
الاولى في الولايات المتحده التي تبني
منزل من سابقين بمساحه 400 متر مربع
تقريبا
ثوره في قطاع البناء وستصبح تكلفتها اقل
من البناء العادي مع مرور الوقت اشاره
سريعه الى ان السعوديه من اولى الدول التي
تخصص برامج لتطويل تقنيه البناء في تسريع
البناء الوحدات الجديده وتخفيضاتها
[موسيقى]